this is the Honda inside a report
brought to you by the 2018 Honda Pilot
with seating for up to eight people and
a hundred nine point two cubic feet of
cargo space it's got all the big you
need to comfortably get you to the big
game see yourself at your local Honda
dealer today test driving the pilot and
he has been the pilot for ten Super
Bowls this is its tenth Super Bowl
coming up this Sunday on NBC the great
Al Michaels how are you good ready to be
this is a oh good I would move the show
here if I were you well you know what oh
you understand um
what type of temperature I'm accustomed
to now living out in Los Angeles 71
degrees in here right and here are this
climate controlled in here it is
definitely climate controlled in here
now you called if I'm not mistaken the
outdoor playoff game between the Vikings
in the Seahawks that was in the
temperatures that were walking around in
right now right two years ago we're
staying in a hotel downtown
and I knew it was going to be cold but I
woke up the game started at noon so I
get up at seven o'clock in the morning
and I look across the alleyway to a
building with a time and temperature
sign on top of it yes seven o'clock in
the morning it said -21 I didn't want to
get out of bed so I started getting
dressed at seven o'clock it was I think
minus 4 at game time but fortunately yes
there was no wind
I mean hardy souls in Minnesota of
course the place is packed that's when
they're building this and we had to play
that game at the University of Minnesota
Stadium and that's the game that Blair
Walsh missed the field goal indeed of
the game in and we had a shot dressed
goth punched up a shot our director as
the Sun was beginning to go get low in
the sky at around 3:00 a glamor this
yeah you saw a breath from like 10,000
people of silhouettes it was remarkable
Jupiter who's incredibly good it was
incredible so here we are at this one
right now now al there's so many
different ways I could go here with you
let's start with this with the dynastic
Patriots this is the second time they
can go three Super Bowls in four years
you have covered some dynasties before
Big Red Machine leaps to
to start off your career what where do
you place the Patriots in the events and
teams and dynasties you've been witness
to right up near the top I think one of
the things too you have to remember is
that when we thought of dynasties years
ago the Yankees tremendous dynasty of
course in the 40s and 50s there were
only 16 teams in baseball at that time
so it was easier to win that much now
there are twice as many teams the
Celtics and the Lakers the NBA was about
half the size when the Montreal
Canadiens were a great dynasty in the
NHL mmm six teams now there are I think
thirty so for the Patriots to do this in
an era when you have the salary cap and
you have the draft and it mitigates
against you being able to do this it's
astonishing and you know I'm a big big
believer in the law of averages if you
you have 32 teams in a league you should
win six Super Bowls every 192 years they
try to do it in seventeen that's a
dynasty that is incredible and you
you've known Robert Kraft for a long
time we talked about Brady and Belichick
and how they need each other or etcetera
etcetera what do you think he's gonna do
when this win or lose and these two guys
Brady and Belichick sit down with him
how do you think he's gonna handle
whatever the situation is that clearly
there's something we don't know what it
is but how do you think he's gonna
handle this now I think they're back
together I'd be shocked if we didn't see
Brady and Belichick next year I mean oh
where was Bill gonna go at this
particular point well that's one you're
right right and Tom I just I don't see
him ending his career the way let's say
Joe Namath did or Johnny Unitas did or
Willie Mays did Pete Rose did I mean
you're they don't look right in another
uniform I I just can't imagine nothing
that couldn't happen but I would be
shocked and by the way Brady is gonna
probably win the MVP award yes I could
you know I know he would be mine yeah he
would be he would be my choice for for
that he would be he's my choice too at
this particular point so I mean is there
gonna be that much of a drop-off between
40 and 41 there might be
I wouldn't count on Al Michaels here on
the Honda inside a report here on the
Rich Eisen show how do you approach a
broadcast like this Sal I know you've
done 10 of them but I'd love to get
inside your skull as to what happens for
you on a Super Sunday well here in
Minnesota you know Cris Collinsworth and
Michele Tafoya and our whole crew we
know about everything there is to know
so we have 18 gazillion things we can
talk about story statistics you name it
but rich I've always felt Chris feels
the same way Michele as well let the
game start see where the game is I mean
I have 18 things that I could tell you
right off the top that would be maybe
interesting but not relevant to the game
you have to fold in your information
that and make sure that it's germane to
the game so I think of I've always
thought of you know the game is the
melody and we provide the lyrics and you
want them to match so you don't want the
game that be over here and you're
talking about some defensive back over
here hey did you know this story no you
can't do that so let the game begin let
the game let the game come to you and
you know one of the things I'll never
forget John Madden before we did the
Super Bowls that we did he you know he
looked at me give me a little fish but
before the game and he said hey let's go
out and make a memory and that's what
you want to do in Super Bowls how would
he say to you he would say let's make a
memory how cool is that that's awesome
isn't that great that is great yeah and
then we did make some memories you sure
did and then before Madden though
obviously you were doing you know Monday
Night Football and then in the with the
ABC crew and that seminal Super Bowl
with the the Gulf War that was happening
90 and the Giants in that game we're
gonna hear a lot about that game we
already have because of Huff Hostetler
was in that game do you see any
similarities at all with Hostetler folds
other than just the obvious yes Ronnie
I've done the two games where the backup
quarterback came into one Doug Williams
yes in 87 for Washington and then
Hostetler so that's good for the Eagles
then that your dad to my scan hey
you know you're looking for the hat
trick blame me if you lose the game or
credit me if you win the game but right
yeah it's somewhat similar the Foles has
had more experience to this point than
Hostetler had going into to that game
and the Giants had you know a very
dominant defense that helped them get
through the playoffs and win it all
Philadelphia's got a great defense as
well the difference in Falls is a little
different in the sense that Hostetler
never had a year with 27 touchdown
passes and two interceptions threw seven
touchdowns in the game all of which
holes has done
I mean Falls looked like he was an
emerging superstar in 2013 and then kind
of went like this then he thought about
quitting
now he's back I mean it does make for a
great story there are parallels but
there there's also big differences
so what storyline that's come across
your your eyes your ears somehow over
the last week obviously you call the
Eagles beating the Falcons you've seen
them you obviously know the Patriots
inside and out that said that which one
do you think have all the storylines
that you've heard this week that you're
eager perhaps to tell people about on
Sunday
you got a tune in and you know okay I
can't give you the whole list right here
but I mean I mean I think one of the
things obviously with Philadelphia yes
is they look so good they're on top of
so many the Power Rankings going into
December
yes Lynch gets hurt now they're dead
well they're not quite dead as it turns
out yes and for the Patriots you know in
a way you go back to opening night they
lose the Kansas City somebody who's your
perfect season and people go crazy it's
it's the Patriots aren't the Patriots
anymore blah blah blah then they lose to
Carolina you know so they're two and two
mmm and such an overreaction to all that
the same thing in 14 remember they got
beaten in Kansas City on the Monday
night mmm you this is in 2014 the papers
are calling for Garoppolo in 2014 come
on I know it's crazy it is kind of crazy
so did you hear Tony Dunne jeez son ask
Justin Timberlake a question yesterday
I'm looking for
kid okay oh yeah I'm going there yeah um
his eleven-year-old son asked him about
how he's gonna get you up
I think shaking your booty al was the
parlance of question yep not quite sure
what it means okay well I think it means
that you're just gonna get some sort of
a groove on at halftime is there is
there a possibility of something like
that happening do you think oh I don't
want to you know that needs to Spence
out of it here but I've got - I got a
call Vegas see what the odds are they
dare to do this is there such a thing
I'm turning on I don't know about the
shake your booty but one online book has
no fewer than five prop bets for what
things al might say during the broadcast
it's it's insane
I can't look at these things because it
will be in my mind I don't think we can
you can do you want influence anything
of that sort to you well I'm not gonna
pay rent coming up are you that when
gaming control knocks on my hotel room
how do you want me to do here in
Minnesota is there any request that you
have of Timberlake at all of Justin yeah
yeah any requests free tickets to a
concert there you go I mean well there
was that at UH at the Hall of Fame oh
yeah that was something did was there
any booty shaking on that night I wasn't
around no no no no the catacombs the
faint catacombs of Canton oh you're the
man I'm looking forward to hearing your
broadcast seeing it and then getting
together when we're back in Los Angeles
we'll do that do that and then as you
know hopefully we can work something out
for yet another Miracle on Ice
anniversary show 38:38 anniversary Al
Michaels check it out tonight up partly
Sunday night pardon me when tow meets
ball with Chris Collinsworth the man
bringing you the action of Super Bowl 52
on NBC when we come back we will decide
who I am taking I'm taking one of these
two of us one and Roger
they'll sweet what do you just plus one
that's it I'm plus one I mean you know
what do you think I should be able to
swing plus two I mean thank you I've got
a good man out Thank You al can you help
with that
I mean eeny meeny lady did not point to
either one of you guys we will decide
that when we come back here on our final
segment here of the Rich Eisen show of
Super Bowl week we will be on the day
after but we will get you set for the
game when we come back the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience